hey friends and welcome back to rapid  fire language learning today we're  answering the question how to improve  your speaking skills  naturally one normal and good piece of  advice is to speak as much as possible  but sometimes we do not have the chance  to do so  so here's my piece of advice that can  change it all  learn to speak to yourself if you learn  to do that correctly first and second if  you learn to do it and make it a habit  make it happen every single day it can  really make  your speaking skills sky rocket so keep  that in mind  and if you want to know more about  speaking skills of vocabulary  acquisition grammar and any other aspect  of language learning please check out my  channel  over and out  you